hagamos algunos ejemplos que pongan a
prueba nuestra comprensión de lo que
sucede cuando multiplicamos o dividimos
una gran cantidad de números juntos y
como siempre pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por su cuenta antes de que
veamos aquí cómo resolverlo primera
pregunta
en cuanto a su signo como es la
expresión x elevado a la 59 entre 2.3 x
x todo esto por cuatro quintos cuando x
es menor que cero esto quiere decir que
esta x es negativa entonces si tenemos x
elevado a las 59 quiere decir que
tenemos x multiplicado por sí misma
x por x por x
59 veces pero recordemos que un número
negativo que se multiplica por sí mismo
un número impar de veces o si tenemos
una cantidad de un par de números
negativos que se multiplican entre sí el
resultado va a ser negativo este 59 las
59 veces que se va a multiplicar x por
si mismo
este es un número impar por lo tanto
todo esto de aquí va a ser negativo todo
esto de aquí arriba bueno ahora qué pasa
aquí abajo aquí tenemos dos puntos 3 por
equis pero x es negativo un número
positivo multiplicado por 1 negativo
siempre nos va a dar negativo esto de
aquí es negativo
negativo / negativo va a ser positivo
así que finalmente todo esto todo esta
expresión de acá
positiva
positivo por positivo pues nos va a dar
positiva así que toda esta expresión va
a ser positiva no va a ser negativa y
tampoco es ser
no va a ser negativa y tampoco es ser
así que esta es nuestra respuesta veamos
un problema más
en cuanto a su signo como es la
expresión menos tres por cuatro entre
menos siete elevada a las 105 bueno
tenemos aquí este número negativo menos
7 que va a estar multiplicado por sí
mismo 105 veces como mencionamos
anteriormente cualquier número negativo
multiplicado por sí mismo un número
impar de veces nos va a dar como
resultado un número negativo si fuera
multiplicado por sí mismo un número par
de veces entonces el resultado sería
positivo pero este 105 es un número
impar así que todo esto de aquí abajo es
negativo lo de aquí arriba este 4 es
positivo así que este 4 es positivo
positivo / negativo va a ser negativo
todo esto de acá
va a hacer negativo y esto está x menos
3 negativo por negativo es un positivo
así que
todo esto
es un número positivo así que nuestra
respuesta en cuanto a ese signo esta
expresión es positiva
no es negativa y tampoco es cero veamos
otro ejemplo
en cuanto a su signo como es la
expresión menos 4.3 entre 7 entre menos
8 nuevamente aquí tenemos una cantidad
negativa aquí abajo y aquí arriba
tenemos una cantidad positiva positivo /
negativo todo esto va a ser una cantidad
negativa y esto va a estar dividiendo a
una cantidad negativa entonces negativo
/ negativo nos va a dar todo esto
va a ser positiva así que en cuanto a su
signo esta expresión va a ser positiva
vamos a hacer un problema más
en cuanto a su signo como es la
expresión 3 elevada a la 0 x 0 a la 26
bueno
aquí hay que tener mucho ojo tenemos que
al menos esta parte es un 0 10
multiplicado por sí mismo no importa qué
número de veces sea siempre nos va a dar
0 esto es un 0 y aparte tenemos este 3
elevado a la 0 cualquier número elevado
a la 0 veces se va a multiplicar 0 veces
es decir cualquier número elevado a la
potencia 0 va a ser cero y tenemos 0 x 0
que también va a ser un 0 así que en
cuanto a su signo pues esta expresión es
un 0 no es ni positiva ni negativa
muy bien hagamos un problema más
en cuanto a su signo como es la
expresión menos 3 elevado a las 73 entre
menos 6.9
esta se ve un poquito más sencilla
esta parte es un número negativo aquí no
hay ninguna confusión aquí tenemos un
número negativo que se multiplica por sí
mismo un número impar de veces 73 es
impar este menos 3 se va a multiplicar
por sí mismo 73 veces un número impar de
veces por lo que el resultado cualquiera
que sea de esto va a ser negativo y aquí
tenemos un número negativo que se divide
entre otro número negativo y queramos
que negativo entre negativo todo esto
va a ser positivo así que esta expresión
es positiva